دبابه ليوبار اثنان الكنديه في طريقها الى
اوكرانيا كما نرى في هذه الصور التي
نشرتها وزاره الدفاع الكنديه مؤكده انها
جزء من مساعدتها لاوكرانيا للصمود في وجه
الغزو الروسي
المساعدات العسكريه الغربيه تتوالى على
كييف وكذلك الوعود بالحصول على اسلحه
طويله المدى في الاثناء تشدد روسيا قصفها
فيتعقد الوضع اكثر على اوكرانيا بحسب ما
يقول رئيسها
كثيرا ما قلت ان الوضع على الخطوط
الاماميه الصعب انها لحظه يحشد فيها
المحتل المزيد والمزيد من قوته لكسر
دفاعنا ان الوضع صعب جدا الان في بخموت
وفوليدار وليمان وغيرها من المناطق
في بلده فوليدار باقليم اشتد الهجوم
الروسي هنا تدور واحده من انف المعارك في
شرق اوكرانيا
يحاول الجنود الاوكرانيون منع الروسي من
الاستيلاء على هذه البلده الصغيره
في منطقه شرق البلاد دائما استهدفت نيران
المدفعيه الثقيله على خط الجبهه بعد ان
استهدفت
التي يرغب ايضا الروس في السيطره عليها
وفق ما اعلنت السلطات الاوكرانيه التي
اكدت ايضا تعرض منشات مدنيه في منطقه
زابوريجيا جنوبا للقصف الروسي قصف تواصل
كذلك على مدينه خرسون الكبيره الجنوبيه
التي استولى عليها الروس ثم انسحبوا منها
في غضون ذلك اكد حرس الحدود الاوكرانيون
صده هجوم روسي على ضحيه بخموت مركز
المعارك في الجزء الشمالي الشرقي
لاوكرانيا
[موسيقى]